they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you they don't want to
know the truth
well you probably know the truth okay so
so there's rudy passing gas
but the content of this was also
disgusting this went on for hours
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
why don't you look at the registered
voters on there how many registered
voters are on
120 percent
should i play this this is one of the
most vile callers we have
take a listen to this i have not
pre-screened this so i let me just warn
you
this may not be suitable for children
for children
hey little prickles now that your uh
your
hero is there are you going to sit there
in your little kimono
and wear your little hat rice because
it's going to be called no free speech
read chinese communist speech
but you can't have pork because you
might offend the ayatollahs
after all you're going to love this too
they're going to make a bomb and i hope
they drop it right on your freaking ass
but you can't have pork but you can't
have pork
but you can't have pork stick that
microphone right up your ass
[Music]
this is highly triggered this is an
extremely triggered
[Music]
there's too much going on to do uh to do
too much of that uh thanks for joining
me i'm so glad that you guys are with me
we are going to hear from
white house press secretary jen sackey
momentarily as we often do because
sometimes streams go down or the audio
goes away we have
three different streams all in audio
visual
format i guess we would say and we're
going to
uh hear from jen saki in just about 20
minutes
i will talk about uh game stop
uh we have recorded a segment about it
already for
uh the broadcast show today and the
podcast which is going to come out very
very soon
i do want to say a very early thank you
i don't know that we've ever had such an
early thank you to
jing zhang i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly
new member number one today at
joinpackman.com
and also an early super chat from
chakuseki
aoc's clap back at cruz was great
but how do you clap back at someone who
is more universally reviled
than the clap that is a great question
that is an absolutely great question and
one which we hope
to be able to answer sooner than later
uh okay um let's see i have i have some
i want to talk about gamestop i have
videos of
toolsie i have uh tweets
i have vaccination numbers and a number
of different
elements and gensake's scheduled to
start in about 20 minutes okay so let's
just get right into it i am
pleased to see that we continue to see
a decline in the seven day rolling
average of coronavirus
cases this is from world amateurs.info
and as you can see
the blue line is the seven day moving
average
it peaked january 11th
11th 12th yeah 11th technically and it
has been on the decline since the
seven-day moving average of coronavirus
cases
is down to where it was right around
december first
that is great okay and let's hope that
this trend
continues as i previously said i
anticipated that the peak
cases would be between january 10th and
15th
and that peak deaths would be about
three weeks after that
the average for deaths has leveled out
from about
january 12th that has leveled but it is
not yet really declining
hopefully we are going to see that
decline soon now meanwhile
in terms of vaccinations the united
states has now vaccinated
25 point well there's been 25.6 million
vaccines
some of these are second doses and we
are up to 1.21 million doses per day
that's a good number i want to get to 2
2.5
3 3.5 million would be my goal of daily
vaccinations
i don't know how reasonable it is but
that's where we need to be
to achieve some of the earlier goals
that were
stated okay so that's that and then very
interesting news
from thailand thailand will soon be
waiving quarantine requirements if you
are vaccinated i anticipate this is
going to become very common
i anticipate airlines that will say you
need a vaccine to fly with us
and i am not surprised to see some
countries start to think about
here are our rules but if you have been
vaccinated
then it is a different uh that then the
rules are different and i think that is
very very interesting
a couple of other notes on vaccination i
think i should mention because people
have been emailing me about
the variants um what we know
right now oh that's weird the super
chats look weird today usually the color
bars don't extend
all the way across the page that's weird
quetracell says david is streaming again
and
another message hi david i'm interested
in learning about media literacy
will you recommend places to start
assume i know nothing
i'm actually unsure what i would
recommend on that maybe just start by
googling media literacy
okay here's my thought so not my thought
here's the research i've done
on variants right now
it appears as though the uk and
brazilian coronavirus variants
are uh well handled by the current
vaccines
and the south african variant is less
well handled
but this is the really important thing
when you hear these headlines
the south african variant uh the
the antibodies are six-fold less
effective against the south african
variant from what i recently saw dr
fauci and eric topel
and others say although there is a
reduction in the effectiveness of the
antibodies against the south african
variant
if you are vaccinated the average person
will still generate enough antibodies
not to get sick from the south african
variant very important
six-fold less doesn't mean that much
unless you know absolute values
and it appears as though it is still
protective uh the vaccine okay
so that's that's what we have uh right
now
as far as information uh what else was i
going to say as far as vaccines go
oh generally i i there's an article in
the new york times and one in the
atlantic about vaccines being undersold
and that it's
influencing people who are saying maybe
i won't get it then because there's a
lot of articles saying
even if you've been vaccinated and your
family has been vaccinated
you still shouldn't hang out indoors
without masks for years or you know
things like this um we want people to
behave responsibly but we shouldn't
undersell the vaccine
the moderna and pfizer vaccines seem
close to 100 effective at preventing
serious covid
and between 92 and 95 effective at
preventing
illness at all altogether and so we
should be clear that
in several months if people keep getting
vaccinated it's going to be very
plausible and
very low risk not zero but very low risk
to have indoor gatherings amongst
vaccinated people
and and i am a little worried about the
degree to which the vaccines are almost
being
undersold and i think we have to be
careful about that as well
um let's see here crash course on
youtube has a great media literacy
series with j smooth
all right david melissa carone is
reportedly running for michigan state
house seat oh my god that sounds like
comedy gold
what does trump say about the variant
who the hell knows
how likely is it biden will keep his
promise and push for a public option
i don't know and johnny tutos says 1.21
gigawatts all right very very important
so we got through that all right let's
talk a little bit about what's going on
with
game stop so i i i don't i did a
relatively extensive segment today for
the podcast and it'll be published to
youtube around four o'clock
okay if i'm not gonna do everything i'm
not gonna
go back to the very beginning but like
the stock market exists and there's
publicly traded companies you can buy
stock in them
okay the long and short of what's going
on with gamestop
and some others uh i believe as you can
see here amc
and blackberry and a couple of other
stocks there have been large
institutional investors and hedge funds
who some time ago determined these
stocks are going down
and we are going to short them shorting
a stock means you are betting on it
losing value rather than gaining value
if you
think of traditional investing you're
thinking of i'm going to buy something
and i think
the value will go up that is called
being long a stock
you might buy a stock at forty dollars a
share
and sell it at eighty dollars a share
right you buy it forty
sell it eighty you made forty dollars a
share
beautiful but if you believe
that a stock is going to lose value
you don't just stay out you can actually
try to make money on the loss this is
called
short selling and it's basically the
reverse of how
most people buy stocks which is
i will first sell it imagine you think
the stock will go from 100 to 50.
you'll say it's 100 now i don't own it
i'm going to sell it how do you do that
well you borrow the shares
you sell it first at 100 then you
buy it back at 50 you pay
back the shares you borrowed and you
made 50
a share now what's the risk to that and
i hope that i'm being clear in my
explanation the risk to shorting
is if i invest a thousand dollars
long if the stock goes to zero how much
did i lose
a thousand dollars what's the most i
could lose if the stock goes to zero
a thousand dollars there's no limit to
how much a stock can
can rise there's a limit to how much it
can go down it can't go below zero
when you shortest stock you're exposed
essentially
to unlimited risk and uh when
some individuals on a subreddit and a
discord
the details don't so much matter caught
wind of the fact that
you had hedge funds betting on the
decline
they started buying up the stock buying
buying buying up the stock and as you
can see here
there's been uh significant growth
recently
and everybody's getting a hot take on
this aoc had something to say
ted cruz had something to say and on and
on and on
um and we are going to see what happens
in the next 24 hours with this
the robin hood app stopped allowing one
to
buy the stock which bids the price up
and only allowed
sales of the stock which is in a sense a
market manipulation by robin hood so
there's all these
little side stories to this but it is a
very interesting story and i have a
quite a segment on it on today's show
okay so that's the game stop story
that's all i'll say for now
i think there are maybe there are some
thoughts on it let me see
matt says david i got a new tv and now
you look shinier what skin care routine
do you use
i i really don't have a skin care
routine
you've got to moisturize though you've
got to moisturize that's it
um okay it doesn't seem that there's
anything else here related to gamestop
on board behind gen saki i like one of
the things is lgbtq plus second thing i
think america for the vaccine should do
is they did forget out the vote
i don't know what gamer batman is
talking about but i really appreciate it
with biden's order to require the
federal fleet to go electric by 2050 the
time to buy stocks and companies that
would power that transition
is now that is uh that is an assertion
via super chat not my financial advice
thoughts on the biden administration's
halt on weapon sales to saudi arabia i
love it
and i have a segment recorded so i won't
i won't spend too much time on it today
thanks to zachary egan who just grabbed
a subscription at joinpackman.com i
appreciate that
i really would love it if you signed up
at joinedpakman.com i'm talking to you
yeah you
um we we are uh continuing to try to
build support in 2021 and i would love
it if you joined and we have this coupon
code better21
twitch subscriptions also count and
eight of them have come in while we've
been chatting
we i got a bunch of people sending me
messages saying david are you currently
at the highest number of twitch subs
in the history of your twitch account i
am
uh 2544 you can see way up there we have
never had
more twitch subs than we do right now
and that's a very
very exciting thing um
could the reddit gme amc bb run lead to
disproportionate regulation
on retail investors and not big
institutional investors
yes yes that is exactly one of the
concerns
currently my 79 year old grandma with
lots of underlying conditions got her
first shot arm was sore for a day but
needed no
relief for pain great to hear that
that's great to hear and the the number
of vaccination centers
increasing significantly i have no
voicemails from any haters today
but i do have one from our friend the
eggman
let's take a listen to it i haven't
pre-screened this this is a voicemail
from our friend the eggman calling in
hey dave i'm really interested in the
story where the 18 year old young man
called the fbi on his father who went to
dc to protest and basically sniffed on
him
um that says one thing that i think you
missed in the
in the story that's a horrible father in
general okay
i have an 18 year old child i could go
do the craziest [ __ ] like that guy did
um on the other side or or who knows
what i could do illegal
and my kid would never rat on me because
i'm a good father to my kid okay
so this guy must have been a shitty
father and a uh
insurrectionist at the same time a good
parent's
child would never rat on them for a
political view
like that uh shalom brother well but how
far does that go i mean is the egg
man saying that if he if if uh if his
kid
knew that he had killed three people
that the kid's still not turning the
parent in for that i think that there's
a line
at which kids would say wow my parent
even if they were good to me they did
something really bad
and um i i think that i don't know about
that
yeah i don't know about a child would
never turn in a parent if you found out
if you knew a parent did something
really really bad
i don't uh i don't agree with that take
i don't think that that's that's not
that's not my take
okay
let's see oh this seems like a weird
voicemail too let's listen to one more
david p what's up uh
i would like to see you get this message
on your show because
a scholar like yourself can't argue
the validity of the statement i'm making
you like to proclaim that fifty percent
more than fifty percent of the country
oh just love joe biden no it's not
i like to proclaim that they love joe
biden
it's i reported on joe biden's approval
rating
i reported on joe biden's approval
rating it's not what i like to claim
well go to his youtube go to the white
house's youtube
uh channel and yeah there was a
coordinated effort to dislike white
house videos that's not
that doesn't tell us anything that means
trumpists are wasting their time
disliking youtube videos that's all that
tears us
tells us just take a gander
at the likes and dislikes of all the
videos
that biden is in okay i'm talking 5 000
likes
hey you know if we learned anything in
the democratic primary
and in the general election it's that
looking at likes dislikes tweets and
follows doesn't tell us who is actually
going to win an election or what public
opinion is
compared to 50 to 70 000 dislikes
you're [ __ ] completely out of touch
bro
no no it's not that i'm out of touch
it's that i'm reporting on
actual approval polling you live in a
bubble
no no this isn't about what's around me
i'm reporting on approval polling
[ __ ] soyboy
you know i listen to your show every day
because
i [ __ ] hate to listen to it ooh hate
hate watching that's good i mean hate
watching actually is a sign of
engagement
it's there's a whole if you've watched
the howard stern movie private parts
actually
the concept of hate watching explains
a lot of different things actually i
don't watch it i can't stand to look at
your [ __ ] face
oh you don't watch you listen okay but i
would love to see you in person
to see if you're actually that ugly that
would that'd be fair yeah i would i
would allow him to evaluate me in person
i don't think it's possible truly
the camera has to it's true
i'm less ugly in person i think that
that's absolutely true yeah we should we
should
evaluate that okay thanks to thomas
mccullum
for signing up at joinpackman.com scott
calderwood and jeffrey vale
new members 11 12 and 13 today at
joinpackman.com i appreciate
that also big thank you on twitch to uh
colors atk and so 8500
who are um supporters number 14 and 15
today
what else do i have you guys want to see
a little bit of tulsi
tulsi gabbard has now made the full
transition
and um well we'll listen to this in a
moment a few super chats
white house youtube full of subs from
four years ago of trump of course they
will dislike it
fair sounds like he's setting up a
murder dungeon as he's leaving this
voicemail
merck has discontinued covet vaccine
development
the right can lie ad infinitum with
impunity yet when the left lies it's
hugely consequential how do you explain
this
asymmetrical warfare oh yeah hypocrite
the right doesn't care about hypocrisy
anymore
and they haven't for a while say more
congressman appreciate your coming on
tonight
so i don't think of you as someone given
to hyperbole you're not throwing wild
charges out there you men
it's already funny measure your words
you said you are concerned that we are
moving towards
a police state tell us why you're
worried
what one second i want to make sure i
didn't miss anything okay i thought
maybe it was starting why are we moving
towards the police state tool c will
tell us
well tucker the very first thing that
any president does
after they've gotten elected any member
of congress and and
every one of us who has served in the
military is we take an oath
and we swear to support and defend the
constitution of the united states
against all enemies foreign and domestic
right trump didn't do that he took the
oath but he didn't do it
the reason that this is the first thing
that we do is because our constitution
is the foundation of this country and
who we are
it is what guarantees us our civil
liberties our freedoms that are
endowed to us not by any man or person
in government but
are endowed to us by our creator
and what
what what that what the hell does this
have to do
so far i'm not getting why this means we
have to be really worried about i guess
now
democrats are bad so this is something
that we must all unite around
this we have to unite around it because
it's it's god-given okay
this is something that we recognize that
those who stormed the capital on january
6 trying to stop congress from
uh fulfilling their constitutional
responsibilities they were acting as
domestic terrorists
true as you pointed out in my video
those like john brennan adam schiff and
others
are also acting as domestic terrorists
because what
hold on this i have to hear because they
are also undermining our constitution by
trying to take away our civil liberties
and rights
that are guaranteed to us uh if you
don't mind i'd like to just quote john
brennan directly
so that people can't say i'm i'm taking
oh hold on i
i feel like i'm hearing the press
briefing start oh no it's not okay i
guess i don't know what that background
noise is out of context
directly john brennan says members of
the biden team who have been nominated
or appointed
are now moving in laser-like fashion to
try to uncover as much as they can about
what looks very similar to insurgency
movements they've seen overseas where
they
germinate in different parts of the
country and gain strength
and bring together an unholy alliance
frequently of religious extremists
authoritarians
fascists bigots racists nativists
and even libertarians
so is the whole proc it sounds to me
that it would be good
to figure out about these uprisings of
everything she mentioned
i guess she's taking issue with the
inclusion of libertarian is
is this all about just the word
libertarian because it seems good to
figure out
where are the white supremacist uprising
the domestic there
this seems all good other than i guess
she's saying libertarian is
let's see if it's just libertarian
that's bad to include
this is the extent that they are going
to to try to
undermine the rights and freedoms that
are guaranteed to every one of us
and it's incredibly dangerous okay so i
think that
we could have a good faith disagreement
about whether
so listen if what they want to do is
jail libertarians
or say that someone that you can being a
libertarian
is probable cause to surveil someone or
to tap someone's phone i would be
against that
being a libertarian alone should not be
a reason to do that now
if intelligence agencies determine
there's a lot of overlap between what
are nominally libertarian groups
and the people who stormed the capital
that would completely justify
having intelligence people trolling
around libertarian telegram telegram
groups or whatever the case may be
i i this is not really seeming to me
like the evidence of the downfall of
america that tulsi is claiming this to
be
dangerous it is so dangerous
and and it's also uh happening on a
greater scale we've ever seen before
because as you point out in the video
that i hope every one of our viewers
will find on the internet
it isn't simply government officials and
our intel
and law enforcement agencies it's also
private businesses it's these giant tech
monopolies
what can the rest of us do to protect
ourselves to keep free speech alive
what in a moment when it's being crushed
all around us
first of all keep speaking i think this
is the most important thing at a time
when
there is so much fear this almost seems
like it's
uh what what's the word for like
pretending wrestling is real what
there's the what's
i'm blanking on the word where it's like
it's sort of it's all staged but we need
to pretend it's real like everybody
knows what role they're playing here
k fabe yeah this strikes me as k fabe
where like we knew what tulsi's role was
going to be in this entire thing for a
while
and uh i what what a just a lame
lame thing uh again i'm not gonna go
over my
analysis of the whole libertarian it
seems like canned yeah
it canned and predetermined it's very
weird very very it's fugatsi
yes i every time i see that word i'm
reminded of
two things an episode of the show bosh
and also the book um donnie brasco
by former fbi agent joseph pistone
who lived as donnie brasco uh who uses
that word when he pretends to be a
diamond dealer
anyway um okay let's move on we're
standing by
for uh jen saki i want to say thanks to
ryan
is it guess ryan goose
i'm sh i'm sorry ryan i don't know how
to pronounce that um
gary mckay and terry baxter
who just signed up at joinedpakman.com
and are new members
number 16 17 and 18 i also want to
say thanks to bruja dormiende
sudden crap dirt dag and a danish
joint for signing up on twitch i
appreciate that and that puts us
at 22 which is it's like a beautiful
beautiful number
um okay the um sign language interpreter
is ready to go
and we're probably very soon going to be
hearing from jen saki
uh the guys the coupon code is working
the coupon code is working i'm seeing
people saying david the coupon code
better21 isn't working it's working
right now
all one word it's working people are
signing up with the code everything's
fine
tucker's listening face is like a
confused haggis
tulsi is part of a cult called science
of identity an offshoot of the hare
krishnas it's no shocker she's nuts i
didn't know that
i don't know if that's true to be honest
i hate watch jessie lee peterson's
program often is that strange it's a
train wreck and makes me laugh but also
cry in despair
i haven't seen what jessie lee peterson
is up to
peterson let's see what his show is
looking like
like lately the fallen state
let's see youtube the fallen
state um will probably get interrupted
here
but i am a little curious let's see what
the recent uploads are
dr tiffany janna mexican christian
socialist
epic debate jesse versus mexican
socialist
hi everyone oh here we go
no guest today hold on let's mute this
here we go we'll get back to them good
afternoon and happy thursday
before we get into questions um and i
promise ample time for questions today
i wanted to share just a few updates
with you
first today president biden signed two
executive actions that will begin to
restore
and strengthen americans access to
quality affordable health care
specifically he directed agencies to
re-examine rules
and other policies that limits and limit
americans access to health care
and consider additional actions to
strengthen medicaid and the affordable
care act
so they can continue to provide access
to life-saving care for millions of
americans
as a result the department of health and
human services will open healthcare.gov
for a special enrollment period from
february 15th
to may 15th and just as a reminder the
prior administration only had it open
for six weeks so this is double
that length of time starting february
15th
americans without health insurance can
go to healthcare.gov
and sign up for health coverage often at
little or no cost
the president also rescinded the global
gag rule which bars international
nonprofits global gag
international funding sorry let me state
this again which bars international
nonprofits that provide abortion
counseling or referrals from receiving
us
funding and he directed the department
of health and human services to take
immediate action to consider whether to
rescind
regulations under its title 10 family
planning program
these also of course build on the
actions the president has taken to put
equity at the heart of his
administration's response to covet 19.
second i wanted to update you on the
amendment being made to the public
readiness
and emergency preparedness act or prep
act declaration on the covid19 response
hhs will amend the current prep act
declaration to permit
recently retired doctors and nurses to
administer covid19
vaccines and to permit anyone currently
licensed to vaccinate within their home
state
and to administer shots across state
lines so we've talked a lot in here
about
the need for not just vaccines but
vaccinators and this is an effort to
put more back vaccinators in the field
love it
a number of states have already taken
action to ease licensing requirements to
expand the vaccinator workforce but this
nationwide access
action will make that easier across the
board the amendment will help us in our
vaccination efforts with a continued
goal of 100 million shots in 100 days
also today i just wanted to point you to
what you may have all seen
the statement by national economic
council director brian diese
about the quarterly gdp and weekly
unemployment claims
and finally a note on the vice
president's schedule today she's doing
local tv interviews and meeting with
editorial boards in west virginia
and arizona to discuss the american
rescue plan
so with that here we go ahead thanks
jenna i've got two one for one domestic
um i wanted to ask you about the
pakistani supreme court's decision
to release the man that was convicted of
the killing of uh journalist daniel
pearl does the white house have a
response and are there plans to
ask for his extradition to the u.s for a
trial
the united states is outraged by the
pakistani supreme court's decision to
affirm
the acquittals of those responsible for
wall street journal reporter daniel
pearl's kidnapping
and brutal murder which shocked the
world's conscience in 2002
this decision to exonerate and release
sheikh and the other suspects in a is an
affront to terrorism victims everywhere
including in pakistan we recognize uh
past pakistani actions to try to hold mr
pearl's murders
murderers accountable and we do note
that as of right now omar sheikh remains
in detention in pakistan
under national security authorities but
we call on the pakistani government to
expeditiously review its legal options
including allowing the united states
to prosecute sheikh for the brutal
murder of an american citizen
and journalist and we're committed to
securing justice for daniel pearl's
family
and holding terrorists anywhere
accountable for their heinous
crimes and the state department i know
also just put out a statement
i wanted to ask about this flurry of
executive orders we've seen
president biden ran on a pledge to
restore unity
he promised on inauguration here we go
for all americans but since he's gotten
into office he's been
largely acting unilaterally he's doing
stuff guys how is that unity
he has not yet met with lawmakers on
capitol hill and we're not even quite
sure who he's talking to on capitol hill
um so what do you say to americans who
are watching this is my favorite he
promised unity but yet he's doing things
the white house think that this is the
best way to make policy considerations
this is the only way right now the
president could come back in four years
from now and erase all the work he's
done
the only way well let me there's a lot
to unpack there so let me let me try my
best it's all packed up
first the president put forward a large
and bold coveted relief package 1.9
trillion dollars
that is meant to address the challenges
the
american people are facing and the dual
crises that we are
that the country is facing from the
pandemic to an economic recession as a
result
that package has the support of the
majority of americans
according to every poll that we have
seen publicly released not republicans
i would say first that part of unifying
the country
is addressing the problems that the
american people are facing
and working to reach out to democrats
and republicans to do exactly that and
yeah this is a good point like 70 of the
country agrees with biden's handling of
kovid
and and unity doesn't just have to do
with republicans in the house and senate
that's exactly what he's doing
he is calling he's had calls with
democratic and republican members of
congress
many of them he's doing more calls today
but he's doing calls
regularly throughout the week and has
done them back to when he was
inaugurated and even
before then but he's also calling
democratic and republican
mayors and governors to talk to them
about what their needs are
on the ground so his objective as
president is to
deliver on what he promised in his
inaugural address govern for
all of the american people by focusing
on
addressing the issues that people are
facing that aren't just hitting blue
states or red states aren't just hitting
democrats or republicans
but are crises that we are all facing
and i think
the the polls will tell you that people
are responding to that
in terms of executive actions um he also
ran with a commitment to
take steps immediately to address uh the
the pain and suffering he said he was
gonna do this and we had a list of his
executive orders returning
some of the detrimental harmful and at
times immoral
policies uh and actions of the prior
administration
but he's the first to tell you as he
said many times publicly
he's not going to take executive action
alone that's why he's put forward a
number of packages
that he's actively working with members
of both parties to move forward on
well if the issue is that congress is so
broken that he needs to work quickly
unilaterally to get some of this done
then does he support
the move towards reconciliation that
senate democrats are talking about right
now it's essentially
the same idea well i didn't say that
that was his point of view that those
are your words not mine
i would say his view is actually that
these policies
the policies in his in his uh coveted
relief package
i would deal with this entire budget
reconciliation thing as saying
the senate is going to have to decide
what they want to do with that
just leave it to the senate like
impeachment everybody thinks that the
american people should get
more relief and a bridge in this period
of time that is such a challenge
so what he's saying is here's my
proposal here's how i think here's how
economists
uh medical experts health experts think
we can address
these crises we all agree are impacting
all of our constituents across the
country
let's have a conversation about it
that's what he's doing at the same time
he's not going to delay
action that can that would that would
help bring relief to the public
and help bring access to affordable
health care to
the american people help ensure women
have access to reproductive
uh reproductive uh health uh health as
well so
you know there are a lot of steps he's
taken over the past couple weeks he's
not going to delay actions that
require immediate um immediate action
that he can that he can bring that
relief immediately but he's also going
to work with congress he's proposed
multiple bills to do that
following up on that democratic leaders
on the hill appear to already be eyeing
reconciliation we heard
uh leader chuck schumer today as they
should with or without republicans
does this undermine your calls for
bipartisanship and are you urging them
to give this more time
well for we're all very close to this
year reconciliation and all the
terminology in washington
everybody who's watching may not be
reconciliation is a parliamentary
process it's a way to get legislation
through
it's a way to get relief to the american
people what i want to see
turn back around is how long should
biden wait for republican support for
the things he's going to do
before he can say i either do it through
but it's it is either done through
budget reconciliation or it's not done
at all how
what's in a reasonable amount of time to
wait he wants this to be a bipartisan
package
he's listening to democrats and
republicans we all are to ensure that
that's
uh what it looks like at the end of the
day but it doesn't seem that you can get
both the speed you want and the
bipartisanship that's right
that's right i don't think that's true
we refute that notion you know these
challenges that the american public
are facing are urgent uh people don't
know how to plan to have food on their
table now
they're worried about whether their kids
can go back to school in a couple months
i would rather see her say
if it's not true it's because
republicans won't come around to do what
their own constituents want
elected officials are hearing from their
constituents and we're confident
that people are going to listen to them
and come together to support a
bipartisan bill
and just one other question on covid the
south african variant has now
been discovered to be here in the u.s
you of course have taken steps to to ban
non-us citizens from south africa from
traveling here
uh that ban goes into effect on saturday
can you explain why why
saturday why not sooner uh
well the testing requirements um we put
in place that you noted um
uh were put in place for all departures
including south africa they take place
they they will be put into effect at 12
at
noon i guess noon on january 26th um
so this actually goes to into effect
friday night fair to saturday morning
close um and was put into place very
quickly over the course of a week to
stand up the necessary process i mean it
takes a little bit of time to put these
restrictions in place to
work with airlines work with uh
regulatory authorities to get them in
place we did that as quickly as possible
and and before there was a reported case
of course because we've seen the reports
and we listened to health and medical
experts go ahead caitlin
so given that democrats have kind of
indicated they will move forward with or
without republican support would
president biden
sign a bill that only democrats voted
for
well we're not certainly hope so getting
us a few steps ahead i wouldn't
why not continues to believe that this
can be
will should be and will be a bipartisan
bill that receives support from
democrats and republicans
and he's having conversations with and
listening to leaders and members of both
parties to
uh assure that we get to exactly that
place but if we got to that place where
only democrats have voted for it
is he okay we'll have a conversation at
that point we're not there yet
second question on given all the
volatility surrounding wall street and
gamestop
what is the bike administration doing to
protect the average american
investor if there is going to be
potentially a major market correction
coming
well the sec put out a statement um i
believe it was today or in the last 24
hours i should say
here we go to that we're not going to
have additional comment from here and
beyond just monitoring it has he had any
conversations with
economic officials about what's going on
we don't he's briefed by his economic
team frequently but i don't have
anything more to read out for you
go ahead is the sec doj or broader
administration specifically looking at
robinhood and other platforms decision
to prevent you here we go
from purchasing certain stocks on
gamestop i don't have anything more on
this aside from to point you to the sec
statement
one more question is the administration
working with uh majority leader uh
chuck schumer to push gary gensler's
nomination given the frenzy on the stock
market
well uh i i haven't i've not spoken with
our legislative team about
gary gensler's nomination specifically
but certainly the president has spoken
about
the urgency of getting his team in place
to address
the range of issues we're facing and i
don't think that would be any different
from mr gensler
um thank you so much uh first on the
covet relief package
in order to cut a deal would president
biden be willing to
entertain a smaller package
well first and you didn't ask me this
but since there was some reporting this
morning i just want to take the
opportunity to be crystal clear
we're not looking to split the package
that is not a proposal from the white
house i talked to the president about it
this morning
that is not what uh our focus is or our
intention is
um and the reason is uh because
um we are not going to put ourselves in
a place or anyone in a place where we're
choosing between
helping families to put food on the
table and
making sure kids go back to get back to
school or making sure kids kids
get back to school and getting a vaccine
in the arms of americans
now at the same time what the president
has conveyed to all of us
and had during his conversations with
members of congress is that
he's put his proposal out there he was
in the senate for 36 years
he of all people appreciates the back
and forth the engagement the opportunity
to hear from members of all
sides on what they like what they don't
like things they think should be smaller
some have proposed things should be
bigger
there's of course lots of ideas no
member of congress is a wall flower
that are are out there in public and
certainly that reflects the private
conversations as well
and you know there are areas for example
uh there has been some discussion of
can this be more targeted you know the
president believes that and
that based on his uh recommendations of
his of economists and his health
and economic experts this is a plan this
is a overall package and proposal that
is absolutely targeted for the people
who need it most but
uh he's happy to have a conversation
about that um and happy to have a
conversation about
um any component that that people are
coming
uh coming at him with good ideas but our
focus is on
maybe i would love an answer because
biden's taking heat for not getting
checks out quickly i would love an
answer which is
joe biden made a commitment to the
american people to get the money and to
get them to it quickly uh
get it to them quickly every day that
things aren't
done is a day that we fall behind our
promise and we're not going to allow
republicans to stand in the way of that
at the end of the day best thing for
domestic travelers here in the united
states and
what other new domestic requirements can
you detail that might be forthcoming
well we had put out just a couple of
days ago as we talked about earlier
uh some specific requirements on
international travel as you know i don't
have anything to preview for you or
predict on domestic travel restrictions
our team is always evaluating and how to
keep the american people safe
go ahead thanks jen can you can you give
the american people
any hope that the vaccine supply is
going to go much over
10 million doses a week for the next
couple months
well as you know but in case people
watching don't know we made it the
president-made announcement just two
days ago about
increasing the supply of vaccines to
ensure that we are getting
as much of the supply into the hands of
governors and elected officials as
as we can to get the vaccine into the
arms of americans
we're going to continue to push as he
said he's going to continue to push
we will all continue to push but the
issue is not
just vaccine supply a big issue is
vaccinators
and the ability capacity to have people
who can put the vaccine into the arms of
americans
and by the way they're already 20
percent beyond the goal that joe biden
said of a million a day
priest we already made an announcement
less than 48 hours ago about
increasing the vaccine supply going to
states he will continue to push
our goal is of course to continue to
increase uh in all of these areas but
the main issue is supply
isn't it it's one of the issues uh you
know we will have we will be in a place
by this summer where we will have
uh enough supply for the public but that
doesn't ensure
that we that everybody will have had a
vaccine because we need to ensure we
have the materials to do to distribute
the vaccine
the vaccinators and qualified
individuals yeah one of the limitations
that's happening in a lot of states
is appointments like you need a few
minutes or however long it is and
there's only a certain time in the day
that you can only pack a certain number
of vaccinators into a certain space
you've got parking requirements traffic
and that type of thing
so even with the supply up there's other
logistical issues dissolved
eu and it's not going to start until
this summer has the white house been
talking
to domestic pharmaceutical companies
about doing something
similar more quickly well uh he did the
president did invoke the defense
production act as you all know
last week but we're not to quote dr
fauci because it's always a good place
to be
we're not producing shoes here we're
producing vaccines
and we are want to work very closely
with the
manufacturers and the companies that are
the experts on producing these to ensure
they can do exactly that it's not easy
to start from scratch in a new facility
we're very mindful of that and so right
now
we're certainly reviewing all options
but our focus is on
continuing to work directly with the
manufacturers and their facilities to
get the vaccines out the door
go ahead um thanks jen and then dita
from the reuters news
um one question on the healthcare eo
today
how many people does the white house
expect will sign up
during the supplemental time
period how many people are you expecting
will sign up for these insurance
programs
through the federal exchange well we
don't have a number to perfect to
predict for you but the reason that the
president
signed the executive order today was
because um it felt essential
at a time of a pandemic when millions of
people are concerned about their health
care many
far too many still don't have access to
open up an expanded window
for americans to be able to apply and we
will have a robust public campaign
public
um paid media campaign to reach the
america i'm reading blackberry with all
of the
stock pushing is actually going to just
switch to doing vaccines there's
really no estimates going in we're not
going to do predictions from here just
as many american people who don't have
access and
currently are not on the exchange that
we can reach will be our goal to reach
and i had to follow up on the on the
markets and everything that's happening
with gamestop
uh you did mention i believe yesterday
um that the treasury secretary is
monitoring the situation and
she's kind of uh on top of it strong
monitors have been
some kind of concerns about her uh
previous engagements with citadel
and speaking fees that she has received
from citadel
are there any plans to have her recuse
herself from advising the president
on gamestop and recuse the situation
well just to be clear imagine after
trump demanding recusals treasury
secretary is now confirmed
obviously we have a broad economic team
uh the sec put out a statement
yesterday that i referred to but i don't
think i have anything more for you on it
other than to say
separate from the game stop issue the
secretary of treasury
is one of the world-renowned experts on
markets on the economy
uh it shouldn't be a surprise to anyone
she was paid
to give her perspective and advice
before she came into office
go ahead before she came in to be the
treasury secretary i should say go ahead
jen i have a couple of foreign policy
issues sure first one is on taiwan
a chinese defense ministry spokesman
said yesterday that
the chinese military activities and the
taiwan strait
is a necessary response to foreign
intervention
and that any effort towards independence
means war
does the administration believe that
beijing is testing the us on the issue
of taiwan
and how would you respond well the good
news is that my longtime
friend john kirby is giving a briefing
today at the department of defense and i
would certainly
refer you to him and any comments he
makes on this specific issue
do you have another question uh so on
i'm just again following up
secretary blinken's statement yesterday
on the
review of the sale of f-35s to the
united arab emirates yes
so missiles to the saudis what is the
message of the administration to the
region
uh in terms of your position on the
abraham accords i understand the
president is open to having more
countries join
but how urgent questions for the
administration
what would be your strategy would you
for example continue the carrot and
sticks approach of the trump
administration
uh well i know uh secretary blinken was
just confirmed yesterday i love having
all these cabinet members and colleagues
and places and agencies because
there's even more expertise out there
but as you know
we've recently paused some arm sales to
ensure they meet our strategic
objectives including
how to end the conflict in yemen but
state
will be able to speak to it in greater
detail and as you also
noted there's going to be an ongoing
review of a range of policies including
what our engagement will be in the
abraham accords in terms of the urgency
how urgent is it for the administration
that more countries sign off
well again this will be under the
purview of the state department um i'm
sure they'll be speaking to it um
and the secretary was just confirmed uh
earlier this week so we'll give him a
minute to
figure out um where his pencils and pens
are it feels like
this is where jen could get some advice
instead of like not answering when
you're asked what is what how much of it
a priority
say you know when we work on so many
different issues
creating a ranking of priority isn't
useful to anyone's goals including our
own
and needless to say it is a priority as
i noted the other day and
as was clear in the readout that we
issued of the president's call with
president putin
um he did not hold back in conveying his
concern and about the treatment of
alexian navalny and the treatment of
protesters
and that is certainly something that
will be continued to be will continue to
communicate
uh at many levels with the russians go
ahead hi uh two questions actually third
i just wanted to follow up on just on
the russia question
is there anything at all that you can
give us in terms of the tone of that
call or the length of the call i mean
the topics that you laid out
boom boom boom were all pretty it seemed
like a quite a difficult conversation
for the russian president perhaps
i'm just wondering if you can give us
any sort of sense of color about
how it went well i'm not in the business
of reading out anything the russians are
doing as i know you're not exactly
asking but sort of
um i will say that president uh biden uh
had clear objectives that he wanted to
get across during that call um he has
never held back
as it relates to president putin or
his concerns about the actions
um of the russian government um and he
certainly conveyed that clearly
during the call as you know there's also
a review that's underway
um about a range of activities that is
being overseen by his national security
team
and he touched on a number of those
issues during that call but i don't have
anything more for you i'm sure
i'm sure the kremlin is happy to give
you a readout of how
how well president putin thinks the call
went uh go ahead
and another question is just on
immigration um
a federal judge in texas has blocked um
your 100-day deportation
um pause i always wanted to see how
that's impacting the biden agenda and
that does anyway
on yesterday's bonus delay in an
immigration eo that we've been expecting
no i will say um i know we had a
statement on
on the specific case you referenced
which i'm happy to circle back with you
on it if you haven't received it um uh
in terms of our overarching agenda and
approach to immigration
you know there was an early and uh and
draft version of the of our what our
executive order
uh plan and schedule looked like um and
that was early and was draft and was not
accurate but i will
tell you get some sleep this weekend
we'll have more to say next
week on immigration um the president
will uh so we'll have
more to report out to you uh in the next
couple days
one final thing here i was curious some
of my colleagues
have earlier been asking you about
reconciliation and sort of the tension
between
moving quickly with biden's legislative
agenda versus sort of a longer
period of negotiation and i do wonder
with this last week
you did have a senator leahy in the
hospital senator mark warner in
you know quarantine because of covid
there's a pandemic going on and you have
the slimmest possible majority in the
senate is there any sort of when you
look at the health
situation is there any sense that
perhaps you know moving along quickly
while you still have a majority might be
the better move
well i've watched senator leahy in
action for quite some time
and uh he has been uh continues to be an
advocate as we know for
justice for equality and uh i um
you know he's pretty wily and fierce so
we're pretty confident we're gonna be
working with him for a while and as you
know he's resting at home and we wish
him
we wish him our best but i would say the
president
came into office knowing he was going to
have a slim majority
and that it would be essential to work
with
both democrats and republicans and that
it would be
extremely challenging if not nearly
impossible
to get a big bold uh work
done on behalf of the american people
without working with both parties and
that's exactly why he has himself
had a number of engagements and calls
with members of congress democrats and
republicans
and why he has asked his team to do
exactly that as well so
we've known uh of course even before uh
even before the election in georgia we
thought the
there wouldn't even be a slim majority
we would be in the minority so
you know he's been planning for that and
we've been planning for that uh
through the course of the last several
months uh go ahead
i'm following up on immigration um i
understand what you're saying about the
document that's
out there uh with some executive orders
and
and dates but the chief of staff also
indicated that
immigration would be coming by february
1st which i believe is monday
so are the immigration executive orders
coming on monday
and is this is there some uh desire to
wait until the secretary
is confirmed for the executive orders or
can you give us
any more shed some more light on this uh
no
i would say as you guys may know from
doing your own planning with long-term
enterprise stories sometimes things
change and uh
things change in communications planning
and what day you're going to put
information out and
there's a range of reasons for that but
i would say stay tuned we'll have more
to say next week
if it's monday or not just sometime next
week it will be next week
one of the executive orders that we're
talking about a plan for family
reunification
at the border and that's one obviously
there's many but that's one that a lot
of people are waiting to kind of hear
what that plan is is that something we
should expect
well the president uh talked about his
commitment to
putting together a commission for
reunifying families he remains committed
to that
and we'll have more to share on that
soon um
thank you so much gentlemen raquel
krahanger from tv global brazil
i have two questions going back to the
climate crisis
during the campaign president biden
warned of economic consequences
if brazil did not reduce deforestation
on the amazon
i'm wondering what kind of consequences
he's considering
if he could hurt for example the trade
negotiations
with brazil or the oecd support
well uh we just announced yesterday that
we're going to be doing a climate
uh summit coming up in the next couple
of months and of course this is a big
priority
for president biden and that's why he
asked
his good friend former secretary kerry
to lead our climate
international effort and certainly
brazil will be a key
partner in that but in terms of
what those negotiations and discussions
look like it's a little too early
for that at this point and i'd certainly
send you to the state department and
secretary kerry's office for more
details
okay so just a follow-up did he invite
the brazilian president will he invite
for the summit
and is also president uh biting still
planning to label countries
uh as climate outlaws and if so would
brazil be part of this list
well we're not quite there yet given we
just announced it there haven't been
invites or anything that went out
um but we're happy she asked good
questions but ones that the press
secretary is rarely able to answer
this is a large emitter uh so is brazil
so is china's or many large
countries in large economies and we all
have a role to play in addressing this
crisis
one more question when does president
biden
think he will be able to start doing
or he'll do his first international trip
and where would be the first place uh he
would go
i don't have anything to preview or
predict for you at this point as you
know we haven't done any domestic travel
yet given kovid
um so i i certainly don't have any
predictions about a foreign trip
go ahead sabrina uh any question on her
confirmation hearing
yesterday uh u.n ambassador designate
linda thomas greenfield
said she believed that bds the boycott
divestment sanctions movement to
pressure israel
is unacceptable and borders on or verges
on anti-semitism
is that a characterization that the
white house shares when it comes
to the bds movement i don't have
anything more for you on
kind of our position it's i think been
that's the president has spoken to this
as a candidate and prior as vice
president um but i don't have anything
new
um and i'm happy to get back to you if
there's anything i can get to you from
the national security team go ahead
thank you rob crilly with the washington
examiner um just to actually follow up
on that linda thomas greenfield
uh also said she would be standing
against the unfair
targeting of israel the relentless
resolutions that are proposed against
israel unfairly
is that the position of the white house
in the is israel after all is in
violation of international law illegally
occupies the west bank and gaza
do you believe it's unfairly talented
you know i didn't see her full
uh hearing yesterday actually i didn't
see any of her hearing i'm happy to
review it and take a look and see if
there's more
we can speak to from our end back to the
executive orders
the questions we were discussing at the
start um so i'm still trying to sort of
reconcile this
daily i think we're at 26 executive
orders now and reconcile that with the
the campaign rhetoric because um in
october
joe biden said there were limitations on
the use of executive
actions things he can't do by executive
order
unless you're a dictator we're a
democracy we need consensus
i i think you said earlier that some of
these executive orders were being used
to
um roll back some of the immoral things
uh that the previous administration had
done
if you're calling these things immoral
is that seeking consensus
and unity this is a weird question yes
the president
biden sees himself as perhaps a
benevolent is there a question well rob
i'm sure this wasn't your intention but
i think you took the president's
comments a bit out of context he was
asked about tax reform
and and whether that could be done via
executive order during the interview
with george stephanopoulos which you're
referring to
well i think that i think the question
is pretty important context for
everybody and he said no
and the president also said during an
interview with columnist
uh back in december that he didn't think
executive action should be used for
everything and that certainly is his
point of view
but there are this is a fake drama where
biden said he would use executive action
for a bunch of stuff and he's doing it
like there's
he's not all of a sudden saying oh i
never mentioned
executive actions now i'm doing them
exactly what he did
now any historian will tell you that he
walked into the presidency at one of the
most difficult moments in history
that required additional executive
action in order to
take get immediate relief to the
american people but he believes
as is as his law is everybody knows how
bill becomes a law uh is that
in order to make action and policy
permanent you need to work with congress
that's why he has also proposed a
coveted relief package
a big bold package some some say very
big um i agree with that
um and also an immigration bill he is
not he's not held back or delayed
putting forward legislation either so
uh he's going to use the levers that
every president
in history has used executive actions
but he also feels it's important to work
with congress and not just one party but
both parties to get things done
go ahead in the back thank you jen a
couple of questions one technical
question on the eos sign today does the
does the eo on
aca open the marketplace to non-citizens
to
legal residents or um undocumented
immigrants that may be able to benefit
from it the extra
good question it doesn't change the
requirements
um for a qualifying for the affordable
care act it opens it up
for three months for people who would be
already eligible for the affordable care
act so
but obviously there are um you know the
the uh health and human services team
will continue to look for ways to expand
access i will say you didn't ask this
but this is a common question so i'm
just going to proactively answer it
that uh we do feel as an administration
that ensuring that
all people in the united states
undocumented immigrants as well
of course should receive access to a
vaccine because that
one is morally right but also ensures
that people in the country are also safe
that was my second question how are you
guiding these things actually yes
okay are you guys the common one yeah
how are you guiding the states if
any in any way to get those undocumented
communities to come forward to get
vaccinated many of them in the states
don't have any way to prove
that they're residents of those states
in order to go to their local
clinics and improve uh residency to get
the vaccine so how are you
working with the states to get that done
it's challenging we've talked about this
a bit in here i mean there's obviously
vaccine hesitancy which certainly exists
in communities of
undocumented immigrants and the concern
of what it will mean for their
status and but we are focused on
ensuring we get the vaccine out broadly
um and to communities across the country
because that will make
the american people safer and it's
something we have to be both creative
about
aggressive about ambitious about is one
of the reasons we need additional
funding
through the american rescue plan but one
also one of the reasons why we plan to
have an
aggressive public education campaign to
help embolden and empower
local doctors and authorities i may ask
one more on
cuba do you guys plan on starting
walking back all of those restrictions
that were put into place under
the trump administration after the obama
administration had opened things up with
cuba
well our cuba policy is governed by
two principles um first support for
democracy and human rights
uh that will be at the core of our
efforts second is
americans especially cuban americans are
the best ambassadors for
freedom in cuba so we'll review the
trump administration policies
as we are in a number of other areas of
national security with an eye to ensure
ensuring that our approach is aligned
with that but
uh you know we will take our own path i
don't i don't have anything to predict
for you at this point in time
go ahead alex um i wanted to clarify
something we talked a little bit about
uh the administration's stance on school
reopenings yeah sure
um so i was like i wasn't really clear
on that so
i got a little better information
indicated that uh
he believes or the administration
believes that schools need more funding
for them to be safe enough
to reopen for students to go back but
there's been a number of studies
including the recent one out of the cdc
that have shown evidence that
schools are perfectly safe for students
to go back and and there were
recommendations that they should go back
so this seems like a bit of a dispute
it's perfectly safe for students
maybe but teacher infections have
exploded like 300 percent
that disappeared well first let me be
absolutely clear
president biden wants schools to open
and he wants them to stay open
uh because it's obviously very
disruptive for families i'm a mother
you know for anyone who has kids for
kids to come in and out of school
but that means making sure as you said
that every school is able to have the
equipment and resources to open safely
not just rural schools or private
schools which often is where a lot of
the
school reopenings and schools staying
open is happening it's a
more of a challenge in public schools
where they don't have that funding from
tuition or smaller populations where
it's easier
to put in place the actions needed to
keep the schools open
but the cdc study which i know has
gotten received a lot of attention
was um based on uh kind of an area that
was more rural
in wisconsin it was not uh and i think
what dr wolenski has said
is that i think she said this on cnn
last night is that
for areas where they are more populated
were schools where there are there's a
lot more foot traffic
that there are going to need to be a lot
of steps put in place in order to
make the schools reopening safe but we
are committed to doing that that's why
the president signs an executive order
last week
supporting the safe reopening of schools
it requires the departments of education
and cdc to provide evidence-based
guidance so
that will include things like testing
smaller class sizes more ventilation
better cleaning ppe strong state and
local public health guidance but
we want to provide that clarity from the
federal government because there's a lot
of confusion and public schools
especially don't know what steps they
need to take how to
ensure they're safe those are all good
decisions that are going to be made
locally but we want to give them the
guidance
that's in process our team is working on
that dr wolinski the cdc and our health
experts and we hope to have more
specifics soon maybe two more questions
go ahead
so american savings rate is has been up
throughout the pandemic
um and so i'm wondering why give all
americans a 1400
check and why not means test for
uh the release that your your
administration is talking about
well first the proposed checks i mean
the the the
um have the same criteria as the package
that received broad bipartisan support
in december right so
approximately the 1400 checks would go
to families making approximately 150 000
a year there's a scaling up as i think
you're referencing up to about 300
thousand dollars i think you are aware
of this but just for everybody else
um and you know there has been some
questions about that
president biden our economic team we're
open to discussing that
but we want to ensure how are they
saying there's no means testing there is
assistance get it um and i would say at
a time when we saw the economic data
today
uh and this was reflected in brian
diese's statement it was
worse than uh any one week i don't want
to misquote myself here
uh than that we saw during the great
recession i mean
people are suffering thous millions of
people are out of work
people don't know how to put food on the
table uh these challenges are real
we it's the data shows it but we also
see long lines for food pantries
uh we see uh you know people who are out
of work and don't know what they're
gonna do
to make ends meet and so that's tangible
that's real and
we want the the pac the packets is gonna
need to be big and bold to address that
since we've been talking about women's
health and access to abortion today
does the administration plan to uh
suspend the requirement that the
medical medication abortion pill be
picked up in person
i know that that's something that
advocates have been pushing for after
the reversal under the trump
administration
yeah i i've certainly seen some
reporting questions about that
um i'll have to talk to our uh health
team about that specifically
can i ask one more about the travel
restrictions sure go ahead and kill them
a lot of our viewers are asking if there
will be
any kind of consideration for waivers
for
students or unmarried couples and
fiances
since that is now the requirement for
testing and quarantine
well i know there's been a lot of
coverage of this and questions because
these are people's lives and human
beings who are missing their loved ones
and their family members
and just to restate what the
requirements are now so spouses of
american citizens
and lawful permanent residents are able
to travel under
uh these restrictions we've put in place
on international travel
although they have to take part in the
mandatory pre-departure testing that
applies to everyone and we are reviewing
and assessing i should say um how
students and unmarried couples and uh
how we can proceed with that moving
forward i don't have anything to preview
for you but we're certainly our team is
looking into that criteria why
countries with high numbers like russia
or india
or mexico are not in the least well our
our health and medical team takes a
close look at
what restrictions we need to put in
place in order to keep the american
people safe
and that's how we review it it's not
about geopolitics i
was at times in the prior administration
that's not how we approach things it's
about
where we need to put restrictions in
place to keep the american people safe i
promise caitlyn should get the next
so just to get some clarification on the
cdc study about schools being
good to reopen precautions or taking is
the white house position that
it needs to be further studied since
you're citing just the one school
in wisconsin or does the white house
agree with the recommendations from the
cdc about schools reopening
well the cdc hasn't issued the formal
recommendations or requirements on how
all schools across the country can open
they did a report as they do reports
frequently um
uh based on uh an area in wisconsin
important in interesting data no doubt
but it that
is not reflective of every school
district and community
uh in the country and so they will be
coming out with more specific
requirements or more specific i should
say guidelines uh for the public because
there are schools that are in much more
highly populated areas
there are schools that have far more
kids in classrooms farmer
kids walking into the school and they
want to ensure that there's
clarity on testing needs class size
needs you know public health guidance
that that people can
abide by but you know their
recommendation is that
k-12 schools should be the last settings
to close
after all of these mitigation measures
have been employed
employed and the first to reopen so we
are all want schools to
to open and be open for good what
what i'm reflecting on or what i'm uh
trying to clarify i guess
is that um you know schools and cities
are dealing with different challenges
than schools in rural communities and
schools in wisconsin maybe dealing in
different challenges than schools in
you know you know downtown atlanta right
so
uh there needs to be um kind of the cdc
will issue
more specific guidelines um soon uh
they're focused on it now
okay and last question on this so
president biden has said he wants all
schools to reopen
in his first 100 days is that still the
goal if
congress does not pass this proposal
which has the money for schools which
brian klein and others have said is what
they believe schools need to reopen
i sense skepticism about the bill
getting passed we don't feel
that uh look i think the reason i know
that's your job um
look i think caitlin one of the reasons
why uh we're so focused on the american
rescue plan and that would have been
when kaylee would have denounced
caitlin collins and the media as an
institution order for schools to reopen
and
for them to have the support to
ensure that they have proper ventilation
better cleaning
testing ppe that's a key component of
the package
and that's one of the reasons we're not
going to negotiate out that versus
vaccine funding or
or you know and unemployment insurance
because that's a key component
and we need that to ensure that schools
will have the resources across the
country
to be able to reopen and that's exactly
what the president wants to happen
thank you jen thank you oh okay we're
good
she was very patient go ahead thank you
i just wonder if there is a general
sense of frustration just about the pace
of things
um you know given the vaccine
distribution you know some of what you
inherited from the treatment for a
weekend
everything's being accelerated you know
working with congress and
sort of having some lawmakers raise
concerns is it harder to change things
than you all thought it would be
uh i i i'm only laughing because we're
on our eighth day here
right so you know and in that period of
time
the president has signed multiple
executive orders
he has proposed several comprehensive
bills
he's had many conversations with members
of congress about the urgency of getting
things done
and i will say on his first day they
went to biden they said
sir we have toilets that have to be
flushed 10 or 15 times i said
what full and optimistic about the
opportunity and the ability to work with
democrats and republicans to get
packages through to help bring relief to
the american public but
we also recognize that members of
congress have
they're not wall flowers they have
different points of view they have lots
of ideas
they're going to bring those forward
we're hearing them and
we're just eager to move things forward
as quickly as we can but we're on day
eight so we are
confident uh we're still on a pretty
rapid pace here
thanks everyone uh i appreciate all of
you i'll be in my office uh thanks for
your time
she appreciates them can you imagine
she's supposed to call them
she appreciates them can you imagine uh
all right there it is
uh another press briefing from white
house
press secretary jen sackey
the room clearing out uh people watching
some kind of golf videos
here at the back of the room um and and
the room uh very
very very strongly clearing out as uh as
we see
all right i've got a big day so that's
gonna do it for me today
but i'll be back with everybody very
soon appreciate you joining me make sure
you're subscribed on youtube and
following on twitch we are getting very
very close to 100 000 followers on
twitch we'll be back soon
you